facebook under fire tonight the
company's leadership knows how to make
facebook and instagram saver but won't
make the necessary changes because they
have put their astronomical profits
before people whistleblower francis
haugen insisting congress must act
against a company she says is misleading
the public promoting hateful and harmful
content holding its ceo to account
haugen left facebook in may armed with
tens of thousands of internal documents
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
facebook is the company that everyone
loves to hate it's a one trillion dollar
giant that raked in almost 30 billion
dollars last year spanning 17 years of
operation and 3.5 billion users across
all of their apps they've consumed 60
percent of all internet connected people
on the planet
facebook literally has the power to
change nations especially in the
developing world and not in a good way
it has long been stated that facebook is
ripping apart the social fabric of
humanity but now the criticism of
facebook is reaching its highest level
yet
in recent days a whistleblower has come
out to highlight the dangers of facebook
and what it's doing to humanity
they exposed how facebook purposely
chooses money over the lives of people
the whistleblower also likened the
company's products to cigarettes for
teenagers and stated the company should
be treated like the tobacco industry
and just before all of this a massive
data breach occurred sharing the details
of 1.5 billion facebook users and at the
same time a major outage saw all of
their platforms go down for over 6 hours
in this episode we'll take a look at the
many troubles plaguing facebook
[Music]
you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
in september the wall street journal
published a number of revealing articles
about facebook's internal workings
one such article revealed how they knew
that instagram was toxic for teenage
girls
it showcased internal documents that
noted one in three teen girls felt that
instagram made them more depressed about
their own bodies
facebook's own internal research also
revealed that 13 of the teen girls asked
said that the platform made suicidal
thoughts worse
it's extremely sad to imagine how many
kids have lost due to the company's
policies
at the time nobody knew how the wall
street journal got such insider
information but then the leaker came
forward on 60 minutes to tell her story
the complaints say facebook's own
research shows that it amplifies hate
misinformation and political unrest
but the company hides what it knows
what makes haugen's complaints
unprecedented is the trove of private
facebook research she took when she quit
in may
her name is francis halgen and she's the
former facebook product manager and she
had a lot to say about her former
company
the thing i saw at facebook over and
over again was there were conflicts of
interest
between what was good for the public
and what was good for facebook
and facebook over and over again chose
to optimize for its own interests like
making more money imagine you know
what's going on inside of facebook and
you know no one on the outside knows at
some point in 2021 i realized okay i'm
gonna have to do this in a systemic way
and i have to get out enough that no one
can question that this is real
[Music]
she secretly copied tens of thousands of
pages of facebook internal research
she says evidence shows that the company
is lying to the public we have evidence
from a variety of sources that hate
speech divisive political speech and
misinformation on facebook and the
family of apps
are affecting societies around the world
when we live in an information
environment that is full of angry
hateful polarizing content it erodes our
civic trust
it erodes our faith in each other it
erodes our ability to want to care for
each other
the version of facebook that exists
today
is tearing our societies apart and
causing ethnic violence around the world
she also mentioned that engagement based
ranking tends to push extreme content to
the top of feeds
and one of the consequences of how
facebook is picking out that content
today
is it is optimizing for content that
gets engagement a reaction but its own
research is showing
that content that is hateful that is
divisive that is polarizing
it's easier to inspire people to anger
than it is to other emotions
facebook has realized that
if they change the algorithm to be safer
people will spend less time on the site
they'll click on less ads they'll make
less money facebook makes more money
when you consume more content
people enjoy engaging with things that
elicit an emotional reaction
and the more anger that they get exposed
to the more they interact and more they
consume
it feels like the sad truth that we all
knew about facebook but now there's hard
proof being shown from the inside out to
the general public
not stopping at her 60 minutes interview
on october 5th francis went before the
u.s senate bringing scathing allegations
against the trillion dollar giant
but i'm here today because i believe
facebook's products harm children stoke
division and weaken our democracy
the company's leadership knows how to
make facebook and instagram saver but
won't make the necessary changes because
they have put their astronomical profits
before people
she told the senate that facebook puts
astronomical profits before people and
they would choose to steer towards
violent or controversial content to
boost engagement over more positive
content
i saw facebook repeatedly encounter
conflicts between its own profits and
our safety facebook consistently
resolved these conflicts in favor of its
own profits the result has been more
division more harm
more lies more threats and more combat
in some cases this is this dangerous
online talk has led to actual violence
that harms and even kills people this is
not simply a matter of certain social
media users being angry or unstable or
about one side being radicalized against
the other
it is about facebook choosing to grow at
all costs becoming an almost trillion
dollar company by buying its profits
with our safety
she told the senate facebook knows that
its systems lead teenagers to
related content and that the instagram
app was like cigarettes for under 18s
and that the company should be treated
like the tobacco industry
when we realized big tobacco was hiding
the harms it caused the government took
action
i implore you to do the same here
she also stated that the company simply
just didn't have enough staff to keep
the platform safe
facebook was literally fanning ethnic
violence in developing countries
examples include myanmar and ethiopia
and this was because it wasn't policing
its service adequately outside the u.s
my fear is that without action divisive
and extremist behaviors we see today are
only the beginning
what we saw in myanmar and are now seen
in ethiopia
are only the opening chapters of a story
so terrifying no one wants to read the
end of it
and she said that the buck stops with
founder and chief executive mark
zuckerberg
francis's lawyers have launched eight
complaints with the sec about facebook
interestingly she's against breaking up
facebook but wants congress to step in
the documents i have provided to
congress prove that facebook has
repeatedly misled the public
about what its own research reveals
about the safety of children
the efficacy of its artificial
intelligence systems and its role in
spreading divisive and extreme messages
i came forward because i believe that
every human being
deserves the dignity of the truth
francis didn't just leave things at doom
and gloom however she gave a clear road
map of how facebook can write its wrongs
and begin to heal society
recommendations include facebook sharing
internal information and research with
congress and other regulatory bodies
and secondly replacing algorithms on
facebook's news feed with simple
chronological ranking
during my time at facebook i came to
realize a devastating truth
almost no one outside of facebook knows
what happens inside of facebook
the company intentionally hides vital
information from the public from the us
government and from governments around
the world
today facebook shapes our perception of
the world by choosing the information we
see
even those who don't use facebook are
impacted by the majority who do
a company with such frightening
influence over so many people
over their deepest thoughts feelings and
behavior needs real oversight
she also urged lawmakers to force more
transparency on facebook and that
algorithms should be able to come under
scrutiny
no one truly understands the destructive
choices made by facebook
except facebook
we can afford nothing less than full
transparency
as long as facebook is operating in the
shadows
hiding its research from public scrutiny
it is unaccountable
until the incentives change
facebook will not change
surprisingly this all seems to not have
been tainted by american politics there
seems to be complete bipartisan support
for the regulation of facebook
in total the senate testimony may be a
catalyst for facebook to change
facebook responded to the hearing
basically stating that francis didn't
have intimate knowledge of the behind
the scenes of the company and wasn't
directly involved in the subject at hand
but she herself acknowledged this and
stated that she had access to insider
research and thought it should be
publicly available
on october 6th mark zuckerberg stated
that the claims were quote just not true
and quote didn't make any sense he also
mentioned that internal research about
the effects of instagram on young people
had been quote mischaracterized
this would have all been bad enough for
facebook but it comes just after an
alleged security breach
i'll briefly summarize
in late september over 1.5 billion
facebook user's information was sold on
a hacker forum
the personal data of these 1.5 billion
facebook users went for a rate of about
five thousand dollars for one million
facebook user accounts
the data contains users names email
phone number location gender and user id
it was obtained through the process of
web scraping more on this later
the data can be utilized for phishing
and account takeover attacks and the
sold data is claimed to be new from 2021
the seller of this data is a group
that's said to be doing this for four
years and they get the data by using
computer programs to simply harvest
facebook profiles which have been set to
public by their owners
unfortunately a lot of people share this
information of their own will
so to be clear no accounts have been
compromised but the public details may
be used to bombard people with
unsolicited advertising
with real-life location phone numbers
and user's full names you can do a lot
of damage sms and push notification scam
phishing attacks or social engineering
attacks are all possible
these users would have to be aware of
spam messages that appear to be
legitimate from a bank a post office
telling you about a package delivery or
many other things if they click the link
their phone or computer could be
compromised and passwords stolen then
these passwords can be used by criminals
or just sold on the dark web
facebook spokesperson joe osborne told
newsweek quote we're investigating this
claim and have sent a takedown request
to the forum that's advertising the
alleged data
around the same time that the data
scraping was going on a massive outage
saw instagram facebook and whatsapp all
go offline for a total of six hours the
outage marked the longest stretch of
downtime for facebook since 2008.
zuckerberg would lose 8 billion in stock
equity as a result
many theorised that the hack was related
to facebook going offline but so far
there hasn't been any credible evidence
to support that
so what caused the outage
according to sanchos generdun vp of
infrastructure quote our engineering
teams have learned that configuration
changes on the backbone routers that
coordinate traffic between our data
centers caused issues that interrupted
this communication this disruption to
network traffic had a cascading event on
the way our data centers communicate
bringing our services to a halt end
quote
so basically it was human error
so from the whistleblower complaint
saying that they put profits before
people
to a hack where 1.5 billion users data
got leaked to a massive outage that
crippled all of their services facebook
is really going through it huh
so what do you guys think
do you think that we're going to start
seeing some political action against
facebook finally so he can start to heal
society i would like to hope so
and i have to say good on francis for
coming out doing what she did is no
doubt risky
a safer
free speech respecting
more enjoyable social media is possible
but there is one thing that i hope
everyone takes away from these
disclosures it is that facebook can
change but is clearly not going to do so
on its own i think every regulator in
this country has finally been handed a
sheet of papers from facebook itself
that says this company is doing harm and
it knows it i think it's gonna it's
gonna take a lot for facebook to get
through this in a way that doesn't
result in a company being radically
restructured whether that's a breakup or
whether that's a governance change which
i think a lot of people would like to
see something is coming this time
if you want to see my previous video on
how exactly facebook rips apart society
i've done one which i'll link below but
i do want to warn you it's a very
confronting watch and does contain some
confronting footage it's especially sad
what it's doing to young people's brains
as well
anyway that's about it from me i'm
working on a video on the evergrand
situation so hopefully that will be done
soon alright so my name is tagogo and
you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you